let's do this question them on hopeful
voice with Bobby and Kamala my name I
like that one that's the same yeah
my name is Miles I'm 18 I'm meeting my
girlfriend's parents next Friday but I'm
black and they're white and pretty
racist any unhelpful advice thank you
well sorry in a situation like that
you're carrying the your whole race on
your shoulder Oh God and whatever you do
dictates you know he'll know oh I have a
complete different ass look at that go
ahead just [ __ ] let me finish [ __ ]
the number-one thing is this is is that
I dated Sarah Hyland not the girl from
Modern Family another one a comic she's
from the south parents white
grandparents are like deeper south old
school they don't like Ching chongs
you gotta build roads but then I know as
a survivor in relationships the the most
important thing is for the parents to
like you and I do it like when I'm even
met Jade's parents in Virginia I her
boyfriend Nick Rutherford's parents I
met them in Oxnard any parents I'm so
good at it cause I think it's important
it's important to have parents like you
and so this black kid right I'm sorry to
say it but you're gonna have to play the
game and you're gonna have to be what
they want you to be don't go in there
going I'm gonna be myself no be like my
brother a changeling change yeah well
cut your changelings Oh play the fake
game it's not even fake it just be the
best guy you can be of you like for
instance it's like let's say you're a
parent okay I mean you for the first
time you're George's dad
[Laughter]
that's what you think yeah what George
is like yeah I'm mr. Krim oh yeah
hello mr. Kimmel I'm Bobby I work with
George ah how did you broke my sunspot
up last week
yeah but you know that's all the part of
the podcast you told him George
you told them about the podcast George
don't get read in front of our graph I
don't want to meet yeah I don't want I
don't want to meet that guy so it's
gonna [ __ ] it [ __ ] what I'm saying yeah
yeah what is your way of handling this
kalila if they're racist you can do
nothing right so just go in there ask
yourself whether you're perfect whether
you show up as the most subservient
[ __ ] Butler or if you show up as [ __ ]
if you came down as Jesus himself and
showed yourself in a black man's body
that's not it's it's not their [ __ ]
racist true listen to me that's not true
not gonna change their mind it is it is
because when I went to the South right
the grandmother was sitting there right
and knitting okay I knew that there was
you know there could have been a thing
like she just could feel the energy
tension right and I go I was a beautiful
grand piano you have it was at her
grandma's house yeah nobody plays it no
one in the family plays gotcha
thing right may I try your pick one I
don't even know if it works or not
and I go let me crack that crack and
then I just played a little tune oh it's
wonderful I go yeah my parents we had
grand piano at home growing up and uh
you know they're really strict you know
my parents said they made me take you
know you you you find a ways into their
[ __ ] heart yes of course that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is go in
there be good be kind be respectful
because those are her parents you do
want but don't go out of your way like
let's suppose they come in he goes in
there and they start making like
underhanded comments about black people
yeah I don't think that he
should sit there and take it I don't
think that you sit there and you're like
yeah you know my people are bad like no
you do that you said you're green oh no
keep your head up high when I first went
to Sarah's house listen when I first
went to Sarah's house she goes you know
there's gonna be a big dinner with my
brothers their kids my grandparents a
bunch of neighborhood people this is in
Louisville Kentucky
geez and then I she goes well let's go
get coffee I went to get coffee and came
back and I walk into the living room I'm
not kidding you the whole place is they
have land Asian lanterns they put up
bamboo what yeah and everybody was
wearing kimonos okay now you're a joke
I'm not kidding you
now you're joking no kimono yeah and
then they had me to wear this kid
Pokemon t-shirt yeah they put it on and
everyone was at your dinner table with
chopsticks and we're all laughing yeah
like crazy oh all right so it's a joke
right yeah right but it's kind of it's
really funny but that's sweet no but no
but there's I could be right two
different kinds of Asian guys number one
this is hilarious I love the sense of
humor or God yeah but this is a fats
mm-hmm right and I could have had a bad
attitude about it Ryan said you know I
mean you know whatever it might be right
but it's how you deal with each
situation no I get what you're saying
but I don't think you do yes I do I I
know my friend Elliott same thing
happened to him loved his girlfriend of
four years but never met the parents
because the parents were just really not
not this that the types of races that
UsWe they were from the South they were
just [ __ ] racist it doesn't matter
what you told them they were gonna stick
to their guns about how they felt about
black people and Elliott was not only a
[ __ ] super stud football player at
Texas but he was really well-spoken kind
just a [ __ ] lovable dude right and
even in her mind she just couldn't she
couldn't bring him home they were that
they couldn't be swayed so in your case
is a little bit
different because I feel like you I feel
like her family probably isn't racist
Bobby she might have had family members
that had a little archaic thinking I'm
saying is this though okay is if I meet
let's say you're white okay and you say
yeah my parents are racist in fact
they're affiliated with you know the
Klan yeah so which means I there's no
way I could probably sway them it's not
I shouldn't be dating you yeah I don't
want that in my life
in any kind of way yeah and so if this
black guys their parents are like that
then get out of the relationship my
guess is because she's bringing him home
argue against that they can't control
their parents you're right George but I
my guess is this you do that oh yeah you
do do that look my guess is this for
this kid you know stop stop for a second
you just made me a very angry okay is is
that if you have a jihadist right and
he's married to a female that's a
jihadist al Qaeda and they have a kid
generally that kid is gonna become a
jihadist what's your point my point is
is this is is that you you know what you
breed and it's it's like you know you
are what your environment is all right
I've never seen a bit your money in the
history of like a jihadist a kid doesn't
grow up and go you know I want to be a
Mormon that's never happened you think
that's happened to George what do you
mean yeah he can't he grew up with a
very religious family he grew up seven
day Adventists
yeah and he's
exactly pretty opposite of that he's not
he's pretty still has seven day
Adventists mentality I know but he is
he likes Gary Johnson and we were just
like that that all stuff I don't know
what it all means but it's a part of
that whole [ __ ] weird [ __ ] you grew
up with all right kids question was that
crazy person my guess is if she's
bringing him home if she's bringing him
home she must know that they're not like
the super racist types yeah but they're
in there they're probably you could
convince them that okay you know they're
probably not as racist as others yeah I
think that's all we have for this week
guys Bobby has his headphones
[Music]